This lecture is about the statistical
language model.
In this lecture we're going to
give an introduction to statistical
language model.
This has to do with how do you model
text data with probabilistic models so
it's related to how we model query
based on a document.
We're going to talk about what is the
language model and then we're going to
talk about the simplest language model
called a unigram language model, which
also happens to be the most useful
model for text retrieval.
And finally, we discussed possible uses
of language model.
What is the language model?
It's just a probability distribution
over word sequences.
So here I show 1.
This model gives.
The sequence today is Wednesday, a
probability of 0.001.
It gave today.
Wednesday is a very very small
probability.
Becauses amount for the medical.
You can see the probability is given to
these sentences or sequences of words
can vary a lot depending on the model.
Therefore it's clearly context
dependent.
In ordinary conversation, probably
today is Wednesday is most popular
among these sentences.
But imagine in the context of
discussing applied math, maybe the
eigenvalues positive would have a
higher probability.
This means it can be used to represent
the topic of the text.
The Mortal Council be regarded as a
probabilistic mechanism for generating
text.
And This is why it's also often called
a generating model.
So what does that mean?
We can imagine this is a mechanism.
That's visualized hands here as a
stochastic system that can generate the
sequences of words.
So we can ask for a sequence and it's
too simple sequence from the device if
you want, and it might generate.
For example, today is Wednesday.
But it could have generated any other
sequences.
So for example there are many
possibilities, right?
So this in this sense we can view our
data as basically a sample observable
from such a generating model.
So why is such a model useful?
So many because it can quantify the
uncertainties in natural language.
Where do  unvertainties
Come from it.
One source is simply the ambiguity in
natural language that we discussed
earlier in Lab 2.
Another source is because we don't have
complete understanding.
We lack all the knowledge to understand
language.
In that case there will be uncertainties
as well, so let me show some
examples of questions that we can
answer with the language model that
would have interesting application in
different ways.
Given that we see John and Fields.
How likely we see happy as opposed to
habit as the next word in a sequence
of words?
Obviously this would be very useful for
speech recognition, because happy and
happy it would have similar acoustical
sound acoustic signals.
But if we look at the language model,
will know that John feels happy would
be far more likely than John feels
habit.
Another example, given that we observe
baseball 3 times and game once in a
news article, how likely is it about
sports?
This obviously is related to text
categorization, an information
retrieval.
Also, given that a user is interested
in Sports News, how likely would the
user used baseball in a query?
Now this is clearly related to the
query likelihood that we discussed in
the previous matching.
So now let's look at the simplicity
language model, called a unigram
language model.
In such a case.
We assume that we generate the text by
generating each word independently.
So this means the probability of a
sequence of words.
Will be then the product of the
probability of each world.
And normally they're not independent.
Right, so if you have seen a word like
language that would make them far more
likely to observe model than if you
haven't seen the language.
So this assumption is not necessarily
true, but we make this assumption to
simplify the model.
So now the model has precisely in
parameters wherein is vocabulary size.
We have one probability for each word,
and all these probabilities must sum to
one.
So strictly speaking we actually have
N-1 parameters.
As I said, text can be assumed to be
assembled drawn from this world
distribution.
So for example, now we can ask the
device or the model to stochastic in
general words for us instead of
sequences.
So instead of giving a whole sequence
like today's Wednesday, it now gives us
just one word and we can get all kinds
of words, and we can assemble these
words in a sequence.
So that would still allows little
computer the probability of today's
Wednesday as the product of the three
probabilities.
As you can see, even though we have not
asked the model to generate the
sequence, it actually allows us to
compute the probability for all the
sequences.
But this model now only needs
N parameters to characterize.
That means if we specify all the
probabilities for all the words, then
the models behavior is completely
specified, whereas if we don't make
this assumption we would have to specify
probabilities for all kinds of
combinations of words.
In sequences.
So by making this assumption, it makes
it much easier to estimate these
parameters, so let's see a specific
example here.
Here I show two unigram language models
with some probabilities and these are
high probability words that are shown
on top.
The first one clearly suggests a topic
of text mining, because the high
probability words are all related to
this topic.
The second one is more related to
health.
We can then ask the question, how
likely will observe a particular text
from each of these three models?
I suppose we sample words.
The former document.
Let's say we take the first
distribution, which had a simple words.
What words do you think it would be
generated?
Well, maybe text or maybe mining.
Maybe another word even fooled, which
has a very small probability, might
still be able to show up.
But in general, high probability words
with likely show up more often.
So we can imagine what gender the text
that looks like a text mining.
In fact, there was a small probability
you might be able to actually generate
the actual text mining paper that would
actually be meaningful, although the
probability would be very very small.
In the extreme case, you might imagine
we might be able to generate the
attacks paper text mining paper that
would be accepted by a major
conference.
And in that case, the public in it
would be even smaller.
But it's a non zero probability if we
assume none of the words have non zero
probability.
Similarly from the second topic, we can
imagine we can generate the folder
nutrition paper.
That doesn't mean we cannot generate
this paper from text mining.
Distribution.
We can, but the probability would be
very, very small, maybe smaller than
even generating a paper that can be
accepted by a major conference on text
mine.
So the point here is that given
distribution.
We can talk about the probability of
observing a certain kind of text.
Some text will have higher
probabilities than others.
Now let's look at the problem in a
different way.
Suppose we now have available of
particular document.
In this case, maybe the abstract of a
text reminding payroll.
And we see these world accounts here.
The total number of words is 100.
Now the question will ask here is
estimation question.
We can ask the question which model
which word distribution has been used
to generate this text.
Assuming that the text that has been
generated by sampling words from the
distribution.
So what would be your guess?
Have to decide what probability is.
Text mining etc would have.
So pause the video for a second and try to
think about your best guess.
If you're like a lot of people, you
would have guessed that my best guess
is.
text has a probability of
10 out of 100 because I've seen text 10
times an there are in total 100 words,
so we simply not simply normalize these
counts.
That's in fact the word justified, and
your intuition is consistent with
mathematical derivation, and this is
called a maximum likelihood estimator.
In this estimator we assume that the
parameter settings are those that would
give our observed data the maximum
probability.
That means if we change these
probabilities, then the probability of
observing the particular text data
would be somewhat smaller.
So you can see this has a very simple
formula.
Basically we just need to look at the
count of a word in the document and
then divided by the total number of
words in the document or document
length.
Normalized frequency.
Or consequences of this is, of course
we're going to assign zero
probabilities to unseen words.
if we have not oveserve a word
there will be no incentive to assign a
non zero probability using this
approach.
Why 'cause that would take away
probability mass for these ovbserved
words?
And that obviously wouldn't maximize
the probability of this particular
observer text data.
But one can still question whether this
is our best estimate.
Well, the answer depends on what kind
of model you want to find, right?
This is made.
It gives the best model based on this
particular data.
But if you're interested in a model
that can explain the content of the
four paper of this abstract, then you
might have a second thought, right?
So for one thing, there should be other
words in the body of that article.
So they should not have zero
probabilities even though they are not
observed in abstract.
So we're going to cover this a little
more later in discussing the query likelihood
retrieval model model.
So let's take a look at the some
possible uses of this language.
One use is simply to use it to
represent the topics.
So here I show some general English
background text.
We can use this text to estimate the
language model and the model might look
like this.
So on the top will have those all
common words like the is way etc and
then we'll see some common words like
these and then some very very rare
words in the bottom.
This is the background language model.
It represents the frequency of words in
English in general.
Right, this is the background model.
Now let's look at the another text.
Maybe this time we'll look at the
computer science research papers.
So we have a collection of computer
science research papers we do estimation
again.
Again, we can just use the maximum
microarrays better, where we simply
normalize the frequencies.
Now, in this case we will get the
distribution that looks like this.
On the top.
It looks similar because these words
occur everywhere.
They are very common, but as we go down
we will see words that are more related
to computer science, computer software,
text, etc.
And so, although here we might also see
these words, for example computer.
But we can imagine the probability here
is much smaller than the probability
here, and we will see many other words
here that would be more common in
General English.
So you can see this distribution
characterizes the topic of the
corresponding tents.
We can look at the even the smaller
text.
So in this case, let's look at the text
mining paper.
Now if we do the same, we have another
distribution again.
There can be expected to occur on the
top, but soon we will see text mining
Association clustering.
These words have.
Relatively higher probabilities, in
contrast in this distribution, will
text has relatively small probability.
So this means again based on different
attacks today or we can have a
different model and model captures the
topic.
So we call this document language
model and we call this collection
language model.
And later you will see how they are
used in retrieval function.
But now let's look at the another use
of this model.
Can we statistically find what words
are semantically related to computer?
Now how do we find the such words?
Well, our first thought is that let's
take a look at the text that match
computer so we can take a look at all
the documents that contain the word
computer.
Let's build a language model.
We can see what would we see there.
Not surprisingly, we see these common
words on top.
As we always do so in this case, this
language model gives us the conditional
probability of seeing the world in the
context of computer and these common
words will naturally have high
probabilities.
But we also see computer itself and
software will have relatively high
probabilities.
But if we just use this model, we
cannot just say all these words are
semantically related to computer.
So intuitively we would like to get rid of
these.
Help.
These common words.
How can we do that?
It turns out that it's possible to use,
langage model to do that.
I suggested you don't think about that.
So how can we know what words are very
common so that we want to kind of get
rid of them?
What model would tell us that?
Maybe you can think about that.
So the background language model
precisely tells us this.
Information tells us what words are
common in general.
So if we use this background model, we
would know that these words are common
words in general, so it's not
surprising to observe them in the
context of computer.
Where is the computer has a very small
probability in general, so it's very
surprising that we have seen computer
with this probability, and the same is
true for software.
So then we can use these two models to
somehow figure out the words that are
related to the computer.
For example, we can simply take the
ratio of these two probabilities or
normalize the topic language model by
the probability of the world in the
background language model.
So if we do that, we take the ratio,
will see that, then on the top computer
is ranked and then followed by software
program.
All these words are related to
computer.
Because they occur frequently in the
context of computer, but not frequently
in the whole collection.
Whereas these common words will not
have a high probability.
In fact they have ratio about one down
there because they are not really
related to computer.
By taking the sample of text that
contains the computer, we don't really
see more occurrences of them than in
general.
So this shows that the even with these
simple language models we can do some
limited analysis of semantics.
So in this lecture we talked about.
Language model, which is basically
probability distribution over text.
We talked about the simplest language
model called unigram them model which
is also just a word distribution.
We talked about the two uses of a
language model one is represented topic
in a document in the collection or in
general the other is rediscovered water
associations.
In the next lecture, we're going to
talk about how, then which model can be
used to design retrieval function.
Here are two additional readings.
The first is textbook on statistical
natural language processing.
The second is article that has a survey
of statistical language models with a
lot of pointers to research work.